dicen que para ser poeta
hay que bajar alguna vez al infierno
la primera vez que entré en la cárcel
no me sorprendió ni el ruido de los
candados y las puertas que se iban
cerrando ni las rejas ni nada de todo lo
que yo me había imaginado
tal vez porque la cárcel está en un
lugar bastante abierto
se ve el cielo las gaviotas pasan
volando y te crees que tienes el mar hay
al lado que estás muy cerquita de la
playa
en realidad las gaviotas van a comer al
basural que está cerquita a la salita de
la cárcel
seguía entrando y de repente veía a
presos moverse por los pabellones cruzar
fue como si diese un paso hacia atrás y
pensara
yo podría perfectamente haber sido
alguno de ellos
y haber tenido otra historia otro
contexto
otra suerte
porque nadie nadie puede elegir el lugar
en donde nace
en el año 2009 me invitaron a participar
de un proyecto que la universidad
nacional de san martín tiene dentro de
la unidad 48
para coordinar un taller de escritura
el servicio penitenciario le cedió un
terreno dentro del fondo de la
universidad en el fondo del de la cárcel
y ahí mismo construyeron el edificio del
centro universitario
la primera vez que me reuní con los
presos les pregunté por qué estaban
pidiendo un taller de escritura y me
dijeron que ellos querían poner poder
poner en un papel todo lo que no podían
decir y lo que no podían hacer
yo ahí decidí que quería hacer entrar la
poesía a la cárcel
entonces les dije que por qué no
trabajábamos con la poesía si sabían lo
que era la poesía nadie tenía ni idea de
que la que quiera realmente la poesía
y además ellos me plantearon que el
taller no era solamente para los presos
universitarios sino que también abarcaba
a toda la población de presos comunes y
entonces yo dije para empezar este
taller yo necesito alguna herramienta
que tengamos todos y esa herramienta era
el lenguaje
entonces teníamos lenguaje teníamos
taller podíamos tener poesía
pero lo que yo no calculé fue que la
desigualdad también vive en la cárcel y
había muchos de ellos que no tenían ni
siquiera un primario completo muchos no
manejaban la letra cursiva apenas una
imprenta
tampoco escribían demasiado fluidamente
entonces lo que hicimos fue empezar a
buscar poemas cortos muy cortos pero muy
potentes y empezamos a leer y le dimos
un autor y le dimos otro autor y al leer
esos poemas tan cortitos entre todos se
fueron dando cuenta de que lo que hacía
el lenguaje poético era romper una
determinada lógica y armaba otro sistema
romper la lógica del lenguaje es también
romper la lógica del sistema al que
ellos están acostumbrados a responder
entonces apareció un nuevo sistema unas
nuevas reglas que los hizo entender muy
rápidamente pero muy rápidamente que con
el lenguaje poético iban a decir
absolutamente lo que ellos quisieran
dicen que para ser poeta hay que bajar
alguna vez al infierno
y a ellos infiernos les sobra les sobra
infierno una vez uno de ellos dice en la
cárcel no dormir nunca nunca se puede
dormir en la cárcel jamás poder cerrar
los párpados
entonces
yo hice así como ahora un momento de
silencio les digo chicos eso es poesía
eso
el universo carcelario está exhibido lo
tienen en la mano todo esto que dicen
que no duermen nunca esto estila miedo
todo esto no escrito todo esto es la
poesía
entonces empezamos
apropiarnos de ese infierno y nos
metimos directamente de cabeza en el
séptimo círculo y en ese séptimo círculo
del infierno tan nuestro y tan querido
apreté aprendieron a que las paredes
podían ser invisibles hacer gritar a las
ventanas a que nos escondiéramos dentro
de las sombras
el primer año que había terminado el
taller convocamos a una pequeña fiesta
de fin de año cómo se hace cuando se
realiza un trabajo con tanto amor uno
quiere celebrar y hacer una fiesta y lo
que convocamos a familiares amigos
autoridades de la universidad lo único
que tenían que hacer ellos era leer un
poema recibir su diploma aplausos y eso
era toda nuestra sencilla fiesta
lo único que yo quiero
y poder dejar
es el momento en que esos hombres a
veces enormes al lado mío o muchachos
jovencísimos pero con un orgullo
tremendo sostenían su papel y temblaban
como chicos y transpiraban y leían su
poema con la voz absolutamente quebrada
ese momento a mí me hizo pensar mucho
que seguramente a muchos de ellos era la
primera vez que alguien los aplaudía por
algo que hubiesen hecho
en la cárcel hay cosas que no se pueden
hacer en la cárcel no se puede soñar en
la cárcel no se puede llorar hay
palabras que están prácticamente
prohibidas como la palabra tiempo la
palabra futuro
la palabra deseo
pero nosotros nos atrevemos a soñar ya
soñar mucho porque
decidimos que iban a escribir un libro
no solamente escribieron un libro sino
que además lo encuadernar on y eso fue a
fines del 2010
hicimos una segunda apuesta y escribimos
otro libro y encuadernar on otro libro y
eso fue hace poquito a fin del año
pasado
lo que puedo ver semana a semana
es como se van convirtiendo en otras
personas
cómo se van transformando como la
palabra les da una dignidad que ellos no
conocían ni siquiera podían imaginar no
sabían que esa dignidad existía y que
podía ser de ellos
en el momento del taller en ese infierno
amado que tenemos todos damos abrimos
las manos el corazón y damos lo que
tenemos lo que podemos todos todos por
igual
de esa forma uno siente que al menos muy
poquito está reparando esa tremenda
fractura social que hace que a muchos
como ellos a muchísimos como ellos los
espera la cárcel como único destino
recuerdo
un verso de un enorme poeta de un gran
poeta
de la unidad 48 de nuestro taller
nicolás dorados
tengo que conseguir un hilo infinito
para conocer esta gran lástima dura
la poesía hace eso cose las lastimaduras
de la exclusión abre puertas la poesía
hace de espejo inventa un espejo que es
el poema ellos se reconocen se miran en
el poema y escriben desde lo que son y
son desde lo que escriben
para poder escribir
hace falta que ellos se apropien del
momento de la escritura que es un
momento extraordinario de libertad
tienen que entrar en la cabeza y buscar
ese pedacito de libertad que nunca que
nunca nadie les puede quitar al momento
de escribir y que también eso les sirve
para comprobar que la libertad es
posible aún estando dentro de la cárcel
y que la única reja que tenemos en
nuestro maravilloso espacio es la
palabra reja y que todos en nuestro
infierno haremos de felicidad cuando se
prende la mecha de la palabra
yo les conté mucho sobre la cárcel mucho
sobre lo que experimento cada semana y
lo que disfruto y me transformo junto
con ellos pero no saben lo que a mí me
gustaría que ustedes pudiesen sentir
vivir y experimentar aunque sea unos
pocos segundos lo que yo cada semana
disfruto y me hace ser quien soy
el corazón mastica lágrimas de tiempo
sigo de ver esa luz
oculta la velocidad de la existencia
donde reinan las imágenes lucha no se
deja ir
el corazón se agrieta bajo miradas
tristes
cabalgan tormentas querrían fuego
levanta pechos a minorizados de
vergüenza sabe que el método no es solo
leer y seguir también desea ver el
infinito azul
el corazón se siente a pensar las cosas
lucha por no caer en lo común
intenta aprender a amar sin herir
respira el sol dándose coraje se entrega
viaja a la razón
el corazón pelea entre ciénagas
bordea la línea del inframundo
cae sin fuerzas y no se entrega lo fácil
mientras pasos de parejos de embriaguez
despiertan despiertan la quietud soy
martín bustamante estoy preso en la
unidad 48 de san martín hoy es mi día de
salir a transitorias y a mí la poesía y
la literatura me cambiaron la vida
muchas gracias